hey guys you know when i was younger
man i was so dumb
when it comes to food i just ate what i
wanted to eat when i wanted to eat it
but then slowly as i got older i got
smarter wiser
and i started to realize just what a big
influence
food has when it comes to our health
and you know even in a day and age we
live in today with all the science we're
supposed to be smarter we humans are
actually very dumb
because we make the wrong decisions when
it comes to food
what we eat and when we eat it and then
we wonder why
am i getting headaches why do i have
gastro
weight gain
cancer
diabetes and the list just goes on
now did you know that there are certain
foods that you should never eat on an
empty stomach
let me show you
spicy foods man i love spicy foods but
here's the problem for some people if
they eat spicy foods on an empty stomach
it can lead to increased acid production
which leads to digestive disorders
now of course you can eat it after
something else but not early in the
morning or on an empty stomach because
if you do you will experience irritation
in your stomach lining
[Music]
citrus fruits now just like spicy foods
if you eat fruit on an empty stomach it
can give you more acid
so instead of you know
when you're lazy and you just want to
quickly grab something and grab a banana
or an apple right don't do that don't be
lazy plan ahead and just eat it with a
proper meal like oats
sugar now this is processed sugar and
also all kinds of sugar that even goes
into fruit juices yeah
stay away from it you wake up in the
morning you're hungry but you think man
i don't have enough time let me just
grab a big glass of juice don't do that
fruits contain fructose
some a lot more than others and that's a
form of sugar that can cause an overload
on your liver
prevention is always better than cure
a lot of people go through life and then
as they get older
they start to get health problems and
it's because of the food that they eat
they develop these habits of unhealthy
food and eating it at the wrong times
listen to me today
change to a healthy lifestyle because
the you of tomorrow will thank the you
of the day if you do it
oh yeah before i forget if you like this
video so far remember to subscribe and
also click that notification bell there
so you won't miss any of my future
videos because if you like this video
chances are you like the other ones as
well and i would really love the support
let's move on to the next one
bananas
now we know a lot of people just grab a
banana if they under run and they don't
have time for a proper meal but it's not
healthy for you not on an empty stomach
why because it can unbalance the
potassium and magnesium in your body
and in so doing it can harm the
cardiovascular system
just eat it with something else
[Applause]
coffee you know i almost don't want to
say that but i have to be truthful
you guys know how much i love coffee
actually i'll add my best options of
coffee for you in the video description
if you want to check it out now most of
us drink coffee before we go to work
right but if you do it before breakfast
on an empty stomach
coffee can contribute to more gastric
juice
meaning acidity in your digestive system
which can lead to gastritis
and in extreme cases to even an ulcer
yogurt i never knew about this one until
the other day which is part of the
reason why i'm actually making this
video according to healthshots.com
consuming fermented milk products such
as yogurt on an empty stomach makes the
lactic acid bacteria present in the
yogurt ineffective due to high acid
levels of the stomach
moreover due to the high acidic levels
the stomach produces hydrochloric acid
which leads to acidity
yogurt in the morning
on an empty stomach nah looks like my
oats is still a winner
raw vegetables
yes i said it raw vegetables some of you
are thinking man i never thought daniel
is going to tell me that vegetables is
unhealthy it's bad for me
well yeah it is raw vegetables
especially green vegetables on an empty
stomach
man i'm gonna get a lot of hate from
vegetarians today but
it's true because they have amino acids
and a few other things that can actually
be aggressive to the gastric mucosa
meaning if you continue to eat raw
vegetables on an empty stomach your body
will show diseases like gastritis and
ulcers
it's not like 100 but
there are chances that it will happen
now if you want more tips on health
check out these videos here and i'll see
you there and before you go
always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys